Game of Thrones provided unforgettable
moments near-perfect episodes and
stunning seasons throughout its run but
as it continued it also changed
television in many ways including a few
more subtle changes that flew slightly
under the radar as Game of Thrones
started its run it seemed to have a
clear main character that viewers were
supposed to rally behind and that
character was Ned Stark as the
Honourable patriarch of the Highborne
Stark family the warden of the north
was lured away from his family and life
at Winterfell to head to King's Landing
the capital of Westeros to become the
hand of the king
in doing so he splinters the stark
family across the map of Westeros
leaving his wife and sons behind as he
and his daughters make a new home in
King's Landing however things take a
turn for the worse when Ned discovers
that the heirs to the throne aren't
actually the children of King Robert
Baratheon but are instead the children
of Queen Cersei and her brother in the
penultimate episode of the first season
he confesses to his crimes in front of
the entire populace of King's Landing
ultimately losing his head anyway fans
of the book saw this moment coming but
for those who had just started with the
show it remains one of the best moments
on Thrones perfectly setting up
expectations before yanking the rug out
from under the entire audience from
older films like Venn her to more recent
epics like the Lord of the Rings trilogy
movies have always been afforded the
budgets and scope to stage enormous
action sequences but that opportunity
has largely been absent from television
even prestige dramas like Breaking Bad
and Mad Men while beautifully shot
remained relatively modest in scope but
all of that changed with Game of Thrones
easily the most technically ambitious
show in television history Thrones
filming spanned continents shooting in
exotic locales like Iceland and Croatia
as it gave fans bigger and bigger
sequences there's a brave men knocking
at our door
let's go kill them while relatively low
budgets during season one prevented the
showrunners from shooting battle scenes
that all change with season two's
Blackwater which led to even more
expensive sequences down the line battle
of the bastards the climax of season six
set new standards and in the show's
final season the Battle of Winterfell
ended up becoming the longest ever
battle shot for television or film for
years television couldn't compete with
film on an epic scale Browns proved it
was not only possible but could yield
some pretty unforgettable results before
a game of Thrones it probably seemed
like a sprawling dense fantasy series
stood little chance of becoming HBO's
biggest hit of all time shortly after
the show's premier in 2011 however the
network clearly realized that they had a
massive success on their hands and got
to work making sure that the show
runners had as much money as they needed
and you will be speaking to me with more
respect
much of the added expense went to battle
sequences with the Battle of Blackwater
Bay bumping the show up to a staggering
8 million dollars for the episode even
then showrunners reportedly had to fight
almost as hard as their characters to
get that increase however by the time
the show reached its final season in
2019 it was breaking records once again
with a budget increase that brought each
episode to a whopping 15 million dollars
and some episodes like the one featuring
the Battle of Winterfell
may have even surpassed that in recent
years 10 million dollar budgets for
prestige TV had been doled out more
commonly but a budget for the final
season that reached 90 million dollars
is pretty unprecedented making it clear
that HBO would spare no expense when the
time came to finish off their signature
show with massive budgets reportedly
already set for the spin-offs it looks
like HBO has few regrets for the first
five seasons of the show Game of Thrones
stuck pretty faithfully to its source
material the novel series a Song of Ice
and Fire by George RR martin which is
currently comprised of five books named
for the first book in the series Thrones
tackled all of its biggest moments
including med Starks execution the
infamous red wedding the doomed wedding
of Joffrey Baratheon and Jon Snow's
death before moving past its source
material in season 6 season 6 came on
the heels of a particularly brutal fifth
season which contained some of the most
hard to watch scenes in the series many
critics and fans believed that once the
show could no longer follow Martin's
strict plot map even though he was a
frequent and consultant on the show the
quality suffered whether or not it was
truly able to hold its own against
Martin's books it still marks a turning
point for adaptations source material is
almost always finished by the time
adaptations are filmed so for the
showrunners to even attempt to move
beyond Martin's books while still
maintaining this story was a massive
feat shock value will always be
synonymous with Game of Thrones viewers
were traumatized by the red wedding and
horrified by Hart home but they could
also cheer as Jon and Sansa defeated
Ramsay Bolton at the Battle of the
bastards as the night king met his
defeat at the Battle of Winterfell or as
Arya changed faces to get her revenge on
Walder Frey
thousand the North remembers tell them
winter came for House Frey that being
said this shock value wasn't always the
show's most valuable or even enjoyable
quality throughout its run it pushed to
new boundaries for what viewers could
withstand the red wedding was bad enough
but watching multiple episodes featuring
graphic torture scenes or the show's
many instances of assaults as a plot
device often felt like too much even so
Browns set new standards for shock value
and if future ambitious show runners can
learn something from its triumphs and
its failures in equal measure it can
only improve the television landscape
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]